das sind sie die männer vom
jagdkommandos soldaten mit
sonderausbildung freiwillige die nach
der grundausbildung für spezialaufgaben
geschult werden harte und entschlossene
burschen eine generation wie erkannt hat
dass wir in dieser gefahren umwitterten
zeit mehr denn je bereit sein müssen
kurze rast wieder entspannung dient die
übung wird fortgesetzt
das exerzierfeld ist diesmal eine ruine
keine alpin soldaten dennoch verstehen
sie jedes hindernis zu nehmen
sie überstehen aber auch jedes
krebsmittel zu erdenken und anzuwenden
es ist der neue stil in der ausbildung
des einzelkämpfers in den modernen
armeen der welt immer mehr bedeutung
erlangen der soldaten dienst ist anders
geworden kein geistloser brill
jeder einzelne ist auch sich selbst
beständen können und härte sind
entscheidend der soldat mit
sonderausbildung der einzelkämpfer ist
das rückgrat der kämpfenden truppe
besonders in einem kleinen her
besonders dann wenn es etwas zu
verteidigen gilt
solches können setzt sportliche
sporttraining braus und erfordert
ständige kondition große willenskraft
und ausdauer
nicht jeder soldat wird sich dazu eignen
es gibt aber auch nicht nur
sonderaufgaben in einem jahr
unser heer besitzt bereits einen großen
kader solch ausgebildete soldaten wie
gesagt lauter freiwillige ein beweis
dass die jugend gewinnt ist echte
leistungen zu vollbringen auch für die
landesverteidigung
unser weg in die freiheit war symbolisch
ebenso schwierig und der weg zur echten
und vollkommenen verteidigungskraft
verlangt von jedem einzelnen von uns
leistungen die letzten ereignisse an der
nördlichen grenze unseres landes zeigten
mit wie viel geschicklichkeit ein
neutraler staat in einer solchen
situation operieren muss sie zeigten
aber auch wie wichtig unser heer als
sicherheitswärter geworden ist heute
wissen wir dass der verteidigungs wille
und die bereitschaft dazu von jedem
einzelnen von uns stärker und fester
werden muss im ernstfall wird jeder
österreich auf seinem posten so bereit
sein müssen wie diese männer mit
sonderausbildung
keine artisten soldaten des bundesheeres
soldaten mit sonderausbildung
männer mit mut die für österreich bereit
sind
ob sie das nicht springen gut auf
schwankendem seil gewässer überqueren
sie den immer verlässlich sie springen
auch befähigt
auch ins eiskalte wasser
soldaten mit sonderausbildung beim hartz
und immer bereit
in der heeressportler kampfschule werden
soldaten die sich für eine längere
dienstzeit verpflichteten in spezial
lehrgängen besonders geschult die armeen
der ganzen welt besitzen sport schulen
mit besonderen einrichtungen die dazu
geschaffen wurden
den soldaten zum einzelkämpfer
auszubilden die kriegerischen
erfahrungen unserer zeit zeigen immer
wieder dass körperliche
leistungsfähigkeit und größte
anstrengungen und jedem einzelnen den
ernstfall verlegt werden
unser bundesheer in seiner modernen
militärische struktur kann und da
anderen her nicht nachstehen
für diese männer beginn jeder morgen mit
einem konditionstraining
die ausbildung ist vielseitig und vor
allem auf militärische sondereinsätze
ausgerichtet
die militärische ausbildung muss dem
einzelnen soldaten auch für den fall
einer ausserordentlichen und schwierigen
situation kenntnisse vermitteln die ihm
die möglichkeit des weiter lebens zeigen
der sogenannten überlebens ausbildung
wird ein teil solche ausnahmesituationen
zu grunde gelegt sie dient auch der
kleinkrieg führung keinen dieser jungen
männer schade dass einige tage in
primitiven verhältnissen zu leben
acht tage und nächte auf sich selbst
gestellt
ein lebensmittel erhielten die soldaten
nur etwas mehl und salz
alles andere musste die natur bieten wer
auf pirsch gang geht ab leisen sohlen
diese männer sind einjährig freiwilliger
unteroffiziere und offiziere der
kommandant erteilt den tagesbefehl jeder
hat seine aufgabe zu erfüllen
hier geht es um das nackte leben wie bei
nestor wird zu spinat baumrinde zu mehl
und vielleicht sogar petri heil
schmecken gibt es auch
das lagerfeuer brennt und dennoch keine
robinsonade eine härteprüfung ersten
ranges in kameradschaftlicher geist der
selbsterhaltungstrieb des menschen in
militärische formen gebracht
eine jugend die sich zu helfen weiß das
tägliche brot einmal anders